what I want to do in this video is to
actually use a graphing calculator to
get some experience on the calculator
itself for graphing some of these
quadratics and actually figuring out the
roots visually by looking at those
graphs so the first equation i want to
find the x-intercept for is y is equal
to negative 3x squared plus 4x minus 1
so we're just gonna go straight to the
calculator I get our ti-85 out of out
here and there are obviously better
things you can use especially on your
computer that are going to be much more
visually interesting and in color and
even faster but many of us have a ti-85
at our disposal and the ti-85 hasn't
changed much actually since I was in
high school or ti-83 or whatever else
there is out there TI 92 and this at
least give you a sense of how to use it
because this is what you have and how to
analyze the graph once you are able to
graph it so let's I already turned it on
so let's input this graph right here so
we click on graph and then we'll click
on this f1 tells us to pick this option
right here this Y of X right so they're
saying Y is a function of X Y is indeed
a function of X so let's click there and
then we're that's going to be negative a
negative 3x let's see where is the
variable there's the X variable x
squared plus 4x minus 1 there is our
function now let's graph it so we want
to pick this choice up here so to pick
the second choice and notice if you want
to pick any of these choices on the
bottom row you can just punch in these
numbers but if you want to pick the the
choice that's above you could press 2nd
and then press that and the second tells
you to pick the thing that's right above
that so I'll pick the thing in the
yellow essentially so I'll do second and
I'm selecting the graph option the graph
option when I was in high school this
was all very fancy stuff but now
compared to pretty much most cell phones
this is pretty archaic but it gets the
job done now let's zoom in because I
really can't see the zero
that well so let me zoom here let me and
I like to use the box it just creates a
we zoom in on a certain area that I can
define so I'll select the box and then I
select where I want to start the box for
using the arrow keys press Enter that
tells it to start the box and then I can
zoom in using the box I define the box
and when I have a box I like I press
enter and it'll redefine it will
redefine the range of x and y values
that it calculates the graphing function
now I want to figure out what these
x-intercepts are so I'm going to use a
trace function and the trace folks she's
just going to walk along this graph so
let me hit second trace and now I'm
walking along this graph as I go to the
right it just increments the x-value
we're getting closer and closer to Y is
equal to zero and it looks like it
happens right at about one right as I
cross one I'm crossing Y is equal to
zero right Y is a very small positive
number here and then it goes to becoming
a very or less small but still a small
negative number right as we cross one
and evaluate it directly at X is equal
to one but let's I think that's a pretty
good approximation we can even try it
out in our equation let's try it out if
if X is equal to one
let me write it this way Y of one if we
write Y is a function of one this is
going to be equal to negative 3 times 1
squared plus 4 times 1 minus 1 so this
is equal to negative 3 plus 4 minus 1
which is indeed 0 so the point the point
X is equal to 1 Y is equal to 0 is
definitely on the graph and this is one
of our x-intercept so let's see if we
can figure out the other one using our
calculator so let's see we need to
figure out this other point right here
let's get the zoom box going actually
let's try just to trace there scrolling
all the way it looks like it's around
point three three
looks like it's around point three three
I suspect it's close to one-third let me
zoom in a little bit better so let me
click graph again click on Zoom I'm
going to use the box again and then let
me do the top left corner of the bottom
of the zoomin really narrowly on that
point right there really really zoom in
so it's around point three three that I
want to zoom in so that's going to be
the beginning of my box then we go right
below the y-axis and then go right above
point three three so it's really zoomed
in on that on that y-intercept right
there so now if i trace it i really
should be able to figure out what that
value is so let me use second and trace
and keep scrolling so it's a little bit
more than 0.33 it looks like it's really
approaching point three three three
three three two three which is one third
looks like it's point three repeating
then we're getting very very small Y
value so it looks like one third so
let's try out one third and see if we
got the right answer so if we have so if
we have Y of one third is equal to
negative 3 times 1/3 squared plus four
times one third minus 1 this is equal to
negative three times 1/9 is negative 1/3
this is plus 4/3 and then minus one or
negative one how you depending on to
view it is the same thing as minus three
over three so this is going to be
negative one plus four minus 3 all of
that over 3 which is indeed zero so we
also have the x intercept X is equal to
one third Y is equal to zero let's do
another one let's say we have let's say
we have one half see let's say we have Y
is equal to one half x squared minus 2x
plus 3 let's see if we can get its
roots or the zeros of this equation
where it intersects the x-axis so let's
get our calculator back and we're gonna
have to zoom out of this thing so let me
just zoom see I know I think I do the
previous zoom well the previous zoom is
still a little bit not too zoomed in let
me do the previous zoom before that I
guess it it keeps zoom previous and then
I do another zoo oh it just keeps
alternating between the zooms so maybe I
have to go maybe we have to clear out I
am NOT an expert at this all right so
let me just input my new graph so it's
1/2 x squared I could write that as 0.5
x squared minus 2x plus 3 and then I
want to graph this so let me second and
graph it oh it's on that super zoomed in
version so let me zoom out the zoom what
zoom maybe oh there you go to zoom
standard that resets it there you go
that's all I have to do the standard
zoom so you see let's see where does it
intersect the x-axis well it doesn't
intersect the x-axis it just goes down
here and then keeps going up so this
this quadratic function right here will
have no x-intercepts and you can see it
graphically here it does not intersect
the x-axis so if you are trying to solve
the equation if you are trying to solve
the equation 1/2 if you're trying to
solve the equation 1/2 x squared minus
2x plus 3 is equal to 0 what you're
essentially trying to do is say what
x-values give me Y is equal to 0 here we
just graphed it it never intersected the
x-axis it just did something like this
it never so it never equaled Y is equal
to 0 so this right here will have no
real solutions and I use the word real
in the mathematical sense there are no
real number solutions will see in not
too far off in the future that there are
things called complex numbers wait and
those can be sold
oceans to quadratics that don't
intersect the x-axis at least in kind of
the real domain now let's do one more of
these let's say we have let's say we
have x squared plus 6x plus 9 is equal
to zero and we should actually be able
to factor this in our head what two
numbers add up to 6
and when you multiply them and get 9 it
probably jumps out at your head it's 3 &
3 so this is X plus 3 times X plus 3 is
equal to 0 or and we just have to use
one of these X plus 3 is equal to 0
subtract 3 from both sides X is equal to
negative 3 so this has 1 0 so how do you
think this is going to look if it only
intersects the x axis at exactly one
point well the best guess is is that
that one point is going to be the vertex
so let's graph it just to verify for
ourselves so let me clear this one out
and we have x squared plus 6x plus 6x
plus 9 and we want to graph it and there
you go it just the vertex is right at X
is equal to negative 3 y is equal to 0
it just hits it right over there so our
intuition was correct and just as a bit
of review and I should have pointed this
out when I was showing you the other the
other graphs notice this has a positive
coefficient on x squared
it is upward-opening the second problem
we did also had a positive coefficient
it didn't enter sect the x axis but it
was also upward-opening and if you
rewind this video to the very first
problem we did you saw it had a negative
coefficient and it also had a
downward-opening parabola or
downward-opening u-shape well anyway
hopefully you found this little this
little practice with the graphing
calculator helpful